frank schirrmacher payback gibt es die
frankfurter allgemeine noch in zehn
jahren also wenn die welt noch existiert
in zehn jahren wird es auch noch die
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung geben da
ich darin kein zweifel habe habe ich
auch kein zweifel dass es die faz noch
geben wird auch noch in 20 jahren
die prognosen die propheten die im
augenblick durch die lande ziehen
schreien etwas zu laut wir sind eine
weltwirtschaftskrise und eine
weltwirtschaftskrise bringt immer starke
veränderung aber auch starke gewinner
hervor
aber es ist so dass nicht nur die
konjunktur einbricht und entsprechend
weniger anzeigen die zeitungen
finanzieren können sondern dass sich
auch strukturell viele anzeigen
verlagert haben in internetplattformen
und nicht mehr in der zeitung
das gilt überhaupt nur für ein einziges
anzeigen segment nämlich für die
stellenmärkte die in der tat wichtige
segmente der zeitungen sind wir erleben
dass zum beispiel das gesamte bereich
von immer zu anzeigen im internet gar
nicht funktioniert das überhaupt viele
anzeigen dort nicht funktion ich bin
aber kein anzeigen experte ich höre dass
eben immer wir unzufrieden auch leute
sind mit den resultaten die sie dort
haben ich würde nie bestreiten dass es
einen strukturellen wandel gibt aber ich
muss doch einigermaßen amüsiert dann
schon fast zur kenntnis nehmen dass
erkannt wird dass wir im augenblick in
einer situation sind wo wir mit der
inklusion großer kernbereiche unseren
gesellschaften aufgrund der finanzkrise
wieder zu tun haben und da natürlich ein
paar zeitungen zunächst mal wegen der
finanzkrise echt in die schieflage
geraten nur die muss man sich dann auch
mal genauer angucken das gesamte
amerikanische modell das in zeitung new
york times ist eine zeit wurde die beste
zeitung der welt aber eine hoch
verschuldete zeitung die irgendwie
diesen schulden runter will die meisten
zeitungen die in amerika betroffen sind
waren hoch verschuldete zeitungen die
zeitung die eingestellt worden sind und
das ist ein ganz wichtiges argument
von denen waren ganze menge
oder ein 2 2 noch gar nicht so viel als
sie eingestellt wurden haben manche
leser das gar nicht bedauert weil die
nämlich im vorfeld ihre qualität so weit
abgesenkt haben das ziel sagt dann
können wir auch gut drauf verzichten
das heißt man muss sich die die
entwicklung dieses gesamten prozesses
sehr genau angucken und dann muss man
anerkennen dass durch die neuen
technologischen formate sich
kommunikation verändert in der welt ich
kann für die faz man sagen wir haben
durch die krise
mehr reichweite denn je auch eine
reichweite sie mal dann der leserkreis
hat sich erweitert elisa die auflage ist
gestiegen
wir haben eine vor ein paar jahren auch
in einer krise eine sonntagszeitung
entwickelt die ist jetzt die
erfolgreichste zeitungs der gründung
seit jahrzehnten und wächst und wächst
was die leserschaft dann geht das im
augenblick nun gerade automobil konzerne
und banken und versicherung keine
anzeigen machen das kann ein ja nicht
verwundern
ich glaube was immer bei dieser debatte
vergessen hat man redet immer von einer
gattung als sei alles gleich wir müssen
hier mal sehen es gibt solche und solche
es gibt welche wir setzen auf qualität
und bei denen ist glaube ich auch in
anführungszeichen die mission noch mal
eine ganz andere und es gibt natürlich
welche die sind auch nur gegründet
worden um geld zu machen
und die haben jetzt sicherlich auch
schwierigkeiten sie gehören die faz
einer stiftung die nicht unbedingt den
gewinn optimieren maximieren will ist
das die voraussetzung für
qualitätsjournalismus dass man einen
verleger hat dann nicht riesen gewinne
erwirtschaften möchte also ich danke
wirklich nicht nur in der krise schon
vorher jeden tag meinem schöpfer dass
wir dieses modell haben dass sein modell
war nach den erfahrungen des zweiten
weltkrieges eine ganz unabhängige
zeitung zu konstruieren
die gründer der frankfurter allgemeinen
zeitung haben deshalb dieses jahr von
vielen sehr beneidet stiftungsmodell
konstruiert diese stiftung hat eine
aufgabe eine zeitung herauszugeben
das ist ihre aufgabe und
wir als herausgeber sind ja auch
mitgesellschafter dieser der punk portal
gemeinden das heißt dann nutzer im
gegenteil sei immer darauf bedacht dass
die dachte dass die redaktion auch er
mitzureden hat dass sie zwischen
symbolisch einen anderen stellenwert hat
als vielleicht in rain verleger
orientierten zeitung
in der gegenwärtigen krise muss ich
sagen ohne dass ich das schönreden will
wie groß die krise ist aber da ist das
ein wirkliches geschenk weil wir haben
die aufgabe eine zeitung zu machen und
diese aufgabe können wir nur erfüllen
wenn wir bestimmte qualitätsstandards
halten trotz anzeigen rückgänge und ich
weiß von manchen kollegen in anderen
zeitungen dass es ihnen sehr schwer
fällt das zu vermitteln die frankfurter
allgemeine zeitung ist da intern
sicherlich in einer etwas besseren
verfassung und trotzdem denken sie weit
im voraus unterstelle ich früher war das
informations geschäft und das
anzeigengeschäft und zärtlich wir
anzeigen stammen wollte brauchte eine
zeit dauern rund um die information zu
finanzieren brauchte man anzeigen heute
sehen sie dass mehr und mehr anzeigen
einfach kräftiger ist auf internet
plattformen erscheinen immobilien
gebrauchtwagen stellenanzeigen erst
recht die sich im grunde genommen gar
nicht mehr abstützen müssen auf eine
zeitung gibt es nicht mittelfristig ein
wirkliches problem der finanzierung von
qualitäts informationen ich befürchte es
gibt es gibt in unseren ländern eine
reihe von bedrohungen für die zeitung
und dazu zählt der anzeigenmarkt ist
aber nicht das einzige wir haben gerade
eine debatte über urheberrechte und auch
über die öffentlich-rechtlichen systeme
in deutschland
was stimmt das kann man überhaupt nicht
bestreiten ist dass die rubrikenanzeigen
im probleme haben im internet
reduzieren und dass das vielen zeitungen
probleme macht andererseits habe ich das
hat natürlich damit zu tun dass ich in
dieser zeitung arbeitet es gibt ja noch
ein paar andere von dieser art auf der
welt und auch im europäischen sprachraum
die als zeitung auch fast
solidargemeinschaft ist das heißt sie
können nicht nur kommunikation und
information sozusagen in einem system im
internet zu sagen dann nachrichten wie
viel ist ich meine 40 millionen deutsche
sind im internet jeder mensch ist im
internet das ist eine
massenkommunikation und dann können sie
natürlich die anzeigen die dorthin
wandern und zum teil auch neu entstehen
nicht ohne weiteres in verbindung setzen
mit einer zeitung die von sich
beansprucht einen bestimmten
qualitativen und auch elitären anspruch
zu haben solange die gesellschaft und
dafür spricht aber einiges so etwas noch
braucht als geometrische nord ist mir da
überhaupt nicht bange wenn sie bereit
ist dafür zu bezahlen wenn sie wenn wir
diese qualität entsprechend liefern
können habe ich überhaupt keine sorge
ich glaube sogar ist es fast zwingend
dass eine gesellschaft solche organe
braucht die werden zum teil im internet
seien die werden aber auch und dafür
sprechen übrigens alle modernen
entwicklung die wir in amerika sehen ist
wird durchaus nicht nur internet sein es
wird immer auch noch prinz sein
ich kann nicht reden für eine anonyme
zeitung die nichts anderes tut als
sozusagen von anzeigenmärkten mann zu
leben dann irgendwie die umfänge
entsprechend zu erweitern aber irgendwie
keine kein qualitätsbewusstsein zu haben
dass sowas hat es natürlich auch geben
da da weiß ich auch nicht wie das
geschäftsmodell wird im sozialen haben
wir mehr und mehr als zwei drittel
gesellschaft zwei drittel das relativ
gut geht und ein drittel der abgehängt
riss der dem sozialstaat anheim fällt
könnte es sein dass wir eine ähnliche
entwicklung auch im intellekt ohren
haben eine ganz kleine schicht ein
drittel die ganz teure information von
qualität zu bezahlen bereit ist und zwei
drittel die sich bedienen lassen von
informationen die oft kostenlos ist aber
von minderer qualität
also dazu gibt es zu führen dass die vor
dieser gefahr schützt uns schon die
demokratisch demokratische struktur
unserer öffentlichkeit
es ist schon sehr schwer das muss man
schon selber sozusagen blind durch die
gegend laufen gute gute informationen
aus dem weg zu gehen die gibt es schon
die frage ist eine ganze andere die
frage beginnt wie früher die frage
bringen dort wo sie wie sich fragen
müssen wer hat überhaupt noch ein
interesse daran nutzt es ihm überhaupt
noch nutzen die reform von informationen
von kulturbegriff viren haben
er hat zum beispiel vor 50 60 jahren
viele menschen sehr genutzt weil die
ganze gesellschaft anders organisiert
war nutzte es ihm jetzt besser wenn er
irgendeine soap opera im fernsehen
gesehen hat vor der beim personalchef
beispielsweise der das auch nur schaut
besser dasteht als wenn er weiss was das
pina bausch gestorben ist dann nehme ich
jetzt ein beispiel eines aus einem
anderen bereich es seit der
globalisierung ist die kenntnis der
internationalen interdependenzen
wichtiger denn je denn die
globalisierung reicht in die hintersten
schweizer bergtäler hinein und man
müsste mehr wissen
seit der globalisierung beobachten wir
aber wie die allermeisten blätter nicht
die faz nicht eine neue zürcher zeitung
korrespondentennetze abbauen
eine bühne der international passive
observer ist zu einem nationalen
boulevardblatt verkommen die großen
amerikanischen fernsehen haben fast
keine korrespondenten mehr eine
provinzialisierung zu dem zeitpunkt da
man mehr denn je was ausland wissen
müsste ja und das ist ja genau der punkt
sie werden hier eine ausdifferenzierung
von informationen bekommen
wir haben nach wie vor unser sehr sehr
groß ist übrigens auch sehr teures
korrespondentennetz ihm wichtig ist dass
der unser leser wissen das aber auch
dass es der leser der zu gewinnen ist
erfährt warum das ein vorteil ist da
fängt es ja schon mal warum er nicht
denkt es reicht mit die meldung die
sowohl auf aol erscheint wie auf
irgendwelchen telekom plattform und so
weiter sondern besser versteht diese
verantwortlichkeit die ihn so etwas
stärkt das man auch jemanden weiß der
das geschrieben hat der dort gelebt und
so weiter ich vermute darum wird es
nicht mehr viele geben
wir werden es sein es werden noch ich
hoffe noch ein paar andere sein die das
auch aufgrund ihrer überzeugung so
machen und die werden immer in
deutschland hat 80 millionen einwohner
es reicht uns sage ich mal das ist
vielleicht eine bescheidene zahl
es reicht uns wenn für die großen
qualitätszeitung von diesen 80 millionen
sagen wir mal 1,5 millionen 2 millionen
wirklich interesse an qualität haben das
reicht sozusagen als als als als als
eine zahl welche von zahlen reden will
und die wird es meiner meinung nach
immer geben selbst in den
demographischen rechten zeit nur was sie
gerade sagten auch darauf möchte ich
hinweisen wir erleben gerade ein kult ja
geradezu ein neues evangelium dieser
neuen technologien da gibt es leute die
bz davis und andere die durch die gegend
laufen und sagen jetzt schaut euch an
was google tut ihre bücher aber gerne
auch noch im papier drucken weil sie
nämlich wissen dass sie das im internet
nicht akkumulieren können was sie dort
akkumulieren können und wir wollen
einmal festhalten
wir haben eine botschaft gehabt die sie
sagen der totalen information der
totalen vernetzung und kein mensch hat
noch 12 stunden vor ausbruch der
finanzkrise nur geahnt dass sie in
diesem das kann schon wirklich
beurteilen weil ich mit einigen der
anderen personen geredet dass sie in
diesem ausmaß jetzt einbricht und am
nächsten tag einbricht das heißt
irgendwas von unserer kommunikations
waren wir da gerade haben stimmt einfach
nicht darauf kommen wir zurück aber
zunächst einmal wenn zweieinhalb
millionen bereits sind für qualität
informationen zu bezahlen dann hilft das
an der süddeutschen einer frankfurter
allgemeinen anderen zeitungen auch in
der schweiz tages anzeiger an der
zürcher zeitung aber das ist ein
ungeheurer verlust an demokratie wenn
von den 80 millionen deutschen die 77 5
millionen übrigen von der
regionalzeitung von ihrer lokalzeitung
nicht mehr behaftet werden mit einer
ernsthaften analyse des weltgeschehens
sie haben recht wobei wir jetzt mal auch
wir wollen ja wirklich nicht man darf
die sache ja nicht so tun als würde
alles jetzt zum ersten mal passieren es
war vielmehr hatten die großen
überregionalen zeitungen sowieso nie
insgesamt als sozusagen gesamt
reichweite auch nicht in andere zeiten
dann allerdings wie sie sagen hatten sie
ihre regionalzeitung hier allerdings
glaube ich sie sagen verlust an
demokratie
ich glaube da muss man auch sagen auch
die zeitung sind natürlich gefordert sie
müssen wir erleben dass
regionalzeitungen einen heldenhaften
kampf führen auch für qualität aber es
gibt eben andere die sozusagen jetzt
großen sparrunde machen und qualität
senken und zum teil
und da wird ja mit recht auch kritisch
darauf hingewiesen dann auch gar nicht
mehr glaubwürdige informationen liefern
da ist eine gefahr drinnen nur die
glaube ich wir sind nun mal eine
demokratie was der mensch ist frei
er möge sich entscheiden er selber ist
also so wir können jetzt ja nicht alles
sagen unsere verantwortung stellen er
muss selber wissen woher seine
informationen bezieht wir bieten sie an
ich bin sicher das wird auch noch
regional zeitungen geben die starke ich
bin sogar sicher dass wir nach dieser
fast virtuellen debatte die wir im
augenblick erleben und die ich sage es
noch einmal sehr viel mit den
verschuldungsraten amerikanischer
zeitungen zu tun hat ich bin sicher dass
die frage was eigentlich papier ist sich
auch noch mal neu stellt die fragen ob
man am computer eigentlich entspannen
kann ob man eigentlich ob das internet
eigentlich ein ort ist der das total
ersetzen kann oder ob wir hier nicht zu
großen ergänzungen kommen ich erlebe
gerade wir haben blogger die in
deutschland sehr bekannt sind don
alphonso heißt einer und thomas strobl
ein anderer
ich erlebe gerade eine total fruchtbare
auseinandersetzung zwischen zeitung
zwischen print und menschen die sonst
nie entdeckt und gelesen hätte und aus
beidem entsteht etwas neues und etwas
was die leser und
konsumenten auch interessiert also was
mich an der ganzen debatte stört ist
diese totaler verfalls geschichte als
geschichte tendenz die sie gerade hat
die durch nichts begründet dass stellen
sie sich mal vor die zeitungen geben im
augenblick leider muss ich sagen ihre
inhalte kostenlos ins netz
fast alle dennoch sind die auflagen bei
den großen zeitungen entweder stabil
oder steigen sogar das muss man sich mal
klar machen wir das ein anderer
produzent eines produktes machen würde
er verschenkt sozusagen einerseits die
hälfte und die andere punkte das würde
gar nicht funktionieren sie sehen dass
hier das wir hier in einer wirklichen
transformation sind und dass die
eindeutigen thesen so nicht stimmen und
ich glaube auch nicht stimmen können sie
sprachen soeben leser als konsumenten ja
vorgänger joachim fest auch herausgeber
der frankfurter allgemeinen großer
schriftsteller auch hat in einem
wunderbaren kleinen buch den gegensatz
zwischen bürger und konsument
herausgestellt zwischen bürger und
verbraucht die demokratie braucht bürger
der markt auch der lesermarkt braucht
konsumenten qualitätszeitungen wenden
sich an die bürgerinnen und bürger nicht
aber der massenmedien betrieb der
eigentlich konsumiert werden möchte das
schädigt die demokratie konsument
benutze dass sie darauf zu sprechen
kommen werden das kann ich bin da
allerdings nicht so kulturpessimistisch
wie man vorgänger wir müssen in der
heutigen zeit gar unterschätzen alle die
transformation dienen wir auch außerhalb
dieser frage internetzeitung unterliegen
ich will für mich ist immer wieder ganz
gerade in england erlebt in der schweiz
führe ich auch mittlerweile ähnliches
wie allen diese bildungsdebatte dass wir
gar nicht mehr wissen wie wir menschen
jungen menschen auch bisschen
information weitergeben müssen wir
müssen da völlig umdenken und ein mittel
ein mittel ist in der tat auch sie dort
ihn dort zu begegnen wo sie bereits
kenntnisse haben es ist nicht fatal und
falsch auch konsum karin wurde auch
konsumenten orientierung vorgeworfen
dazu betonen wer denn sie sind es ja
auch und dass man darüber hinaus
allerdings
auch bildungsmöglichkeiten eröffnen kann
ist ja der trick den man versucht aber
die wissensgesellschaft ist doch im
wesentlichen unterhaltungs gesellschaft
abgesehen von ein paar blätter tragen da
immer irgendwie den falschen weil ich
will gerne auf die andere nicht wir sind
das bestimmt nicht wir sagen jede woche
jeden tag in der woche in der
sonntagszeitung ja das war ja das große
die große idee ihn sozusagen politik
wirtschaft und fördern gleichberechtigt
in so einem blatt zu implantieren
dass man sagt der bank hat der das liest
und diese marke die ja sehr
vertrauenswürdig ist an die glaubt deren
im zur kenntnis selbst wenn das sich
schließt kultur ist offenbar auch
wichtig denn die haben ein ganz eigenes
produkt dafür und umgekehrt der
kulturinteressierte sagt naja wenn mein
buch hier besprochen wird kann es sein
dass mich auch sozusagen ein politiker
die das zur kenntnis in bahrain
tatsächlich an kosmos ist das ist die
idee dieser zeitung gewesen dass züge
weil ich sehe auch die idee dann in
gewisser weise neue zürcher gewesen
und sicherlich auch andere zeitungen
deutschland nur was darüber hinaus in
dieser medienwelt passiert darf man
nicht ganz losgelöst lassen von den
demografischen entwicklungen denen wir
unterworfen sind
wir haben eine eine ein immer größeres
problem mit dem was wir die
bildungsferne schichten nennen es viel
zu wenig passiert
da haben wie ich finde auch die
zeitungsverleger insgesamt geschlafen
diese ganzen projekte die jetzt gab es
der zeitung in der schule aber das hätte
man viel intensiver machen müssen auch
mal diese sie tun es jetzt ja vielleicht
kommt daraus etwas eine gefahr für die
demokratie ist wenn es in der tat nur
noch medien gibt die dieses bedienen und
wenn sogar die öffentlich-rechtlichen
systeme die es gar nicht müssten erst
dann auch noch tun
das wäre in der tat und daran kann ich
nur schlussfolgern es ist absolut
notwendig dass es in dieser gesellschaft
zeitungen dass der zeitungen sind die
sich dem nicht unterwerfen
das sind die qualitätszeitungen in der
europäischen gesellschaft sprechen wir
von dieser qualität die indirekt übte
selbstkritik als sie sagten das noch
wenige stunden vor ausbruch der
finanzkrise
der gesamte informations betrieb das was
auf uns zu kam gar nicht erfasst hatte
sie ergeben die eine zeitung heraus die
das finanz kapitalistische das jetzt
eingebrochen ist über viele jahre fast
schon publizistisch verkörpert hat ja
das sagen sie in der faz gehabt gibt es
steht in der bibel meines vaters sind
viele wohnungen da ist in jedem der
teide überall dieses immer kontrovers
diskutiert worden die die natürlich ist
den wirtschaftsteil etwas anderes sein
vertrauen das ich zuständig bin oder
einer politik und es war ehrlich
gestanden auch nicht selbstkritik
da bin ich gerne bereit zu der
selbstkritik es war er kritik an diesem
versuch also sagen hier etwas zu
erkennen wenn es wirklich stimmt dass
diese neuen informationstechnologien und
zu bereichern
so zeigen die nichts mehr im verborgenen
bleibt es ist immer irgendwo jemand gibt
der über twitter das ist jetzt in dem
fall vielleicht das falsche beispiel den
ersten unfall gleich fotografierte da
passiert muss es uns einfach zu denken
geben dass die information so die die
dass diese finanzkrise betrafen dass die
alle überraschten die außen war nicht
die innen waren
jetzt ein jahr später veröffentlichte
amerikanische kongress der senat auf
seiner webpage die geheime e mails von
lehmann die dem den kommunikations
datenverkehr und so weit wie jetzt kann
man nachlesen was da passierte und sich
darauf baute aber zu dem zeitpunkt als
das passierte war das nicht und damit
das sage ich ja nur deshalb weil ich
sagen will wir werden nie es wird nie
kommunikative systeme geben wie es jetzt
zum teil die die totale transparenz
bedeuten
es wird etwas viel anderes etwas anderes
viel wichtiger seien interpretation und
analyse und dieser interpretation dieser
analyse letztlich manchmal dieses system
kritik wäre nötiger denn je gewesen zu
einem zeitpunkt da man systemkritik
diskreditiert hatte weil man das als
68er ish abtat ja da ist was dran ich
finde dass ich da hab da übrigens auch
selber gelernt also ich muss sagen ich
habe die sie ändern sich an die gerade
in deutschland war das schon sehr stark
dieser sogenannte neoliberale diskurs
und was ein daran überzeugte
ich bin nicht vom fach war dass man so
glaubt dass rational das ist halt so da
spricht die rationalität dann hatten wir
dieses schlagwort globalisierung
dann hatten wir das gefühl hier wird
vernünftig hier geht es um die 5 gesamt
liefern und jede ideologie und das
stellt rationalität des menschen ja aber
hier geht genau hier ging es um die
rationalität das rationale handeln des
einzelnen und sie können das jetzt
ideologie nicht metrologie die ideologie
wird in dem augenblick da raus sagte die
zu seinem vorteil ist und er in diesem
fall als marktteilnehmer handelt auch
nie gegen seinen eigenen vorteil
was wir jetzt gesehen haben was eine
sehr fragile these ist bei der
mittlerweile das sind die behavioral
economics hatte obama sich hierfür als
ökonomen der sich sozusagen auf die
psychologie genau eigentliche verhalten
des menschen interessant hochinteressant
das eine hochinteressante gruppe
die sich gerade der amerikanische
präsident hat und die ja gerade diesen
homo ökonomie kurs von denen wir hier
immer reden massiv in frage stellen ihr
folgten gegenprogramm genug ich will ja
gar nicht so dass ja vermessen so etwas
zu sagen und ich sage nochmal auch
selbstkritisch ich hab das auch nicht
geahnt ich habe das alles was ich habe
diese nehmen sie sonst für von warren
buffett den wir alle kennen diese
derivate sind amerikanische großbanken
genau die sind massenvernichtungswaffen
oder dergleichen
das hat man so wie ein stück literatur
zur kenntnis genommen hat gerade
irgendwann man hat doch gehört blase
entsteht nur die sozusagen das
systemische dieser krise die das ich
aufbaut
das hat natürlich hat niemand von uns
gesehen und ich sage jetzt ja gerade
sagen was ich gelernt habe daraus was
sie genau sie sagen man hat aufgrund
einer sozialisation 70er 80er jahre
immer gedacht systemkritik acht es ist
das alte lied das ist der dritte weg der
sand bestimmtes milieu und so weiter das
ist etwas was man jetzt erkennt nein das
ist nicht mehr da sind wir dann sind wir
darüber hinaus wir müssen systemkritik
führen wir müssen uns fragen ganz banale
fragen stellen die ja viele berühmte
leute wie krugman andere sich auch
stellen ist es noch gerechtfertigt dass
sich eine gruppe der gesellschaft so
abspaltet auch ökonomisch ab
von der gesamtgruppe wir wissen jetzt
was passiert wenn sie sich so abspaltet
zu hohe boni und gehälter und was auch
immer hat die atemberaubend sind dann
verliert sie und das kann man nachweisen
automatisch die verantwortung für das
ganze team wird zum wirtschafts
gesellschafts teil wenn wir denn wie
eine marktgesellschaft und nicht mehr in
einer marktwirtschaft sind
das wird ja immer irgendwie versucht
hier immer kunst künstler schriftsteller
versuchen immer das ganze zu verstehen
ich glaube und darum das stichwort
ökonomie und psychologie in der
migration wird es doch anmaßen ein
wirtschaftsteil
das ist gar nicht möglich wird das fängt
an beim bilanzen lesen und trat auch bei
ganz anderen dingen
ich glaube das gesamte gesamtheit des
diskurses ist wichtig bei uns in der
zeitung ist eine ein lebendiger
austausch von dem man auch lernt wenn
ich dann sehe welche debatten zum
beispiel wenn im wirtschaftsteil der faz
nicht emersacker man es gab mal eben
über faust und die ökonomische theorie
mit seinem doktorvater binswanger
diskutiert das ist total aufregend und
faszinierend daraus entstehen eigentlich
ökonomische diskursive räume die dann
wieder andere menschen portal die man
vorher nicht erreicht hätte erreichte
aber dass förderung ist kann natürlich
kein wirtschaftsförderer wird andere
fragen stellen müssen und die sind ganz
wichtig die zum beispiel glaube ich ist
eine ganz große frage mittlerweile die
frage nicht nur warum blockiert sich der
staat warum ist der staat so wenig in
der lage reformen zu veranstalten
sondern die frage der zukunft wird auch
sein was macht eigentlich in uns das aus
als individuen dass wir uns ständig
blockieren ich meine es auf einer ganz
auch banal psychologischen ebene welche
unserer konstruktion sind so
demotivierend auch aus der vergangenheit
nie reformiert worden bestimmte
vorstellungen die man über lebensläufe
hat über karrieren hat über die frage
wann familien der bei die arbeitgeber
mit familienbildung umgehen usw war
warum ist das alles so die motivieren
das sind fragen die sich allmählich als
sehr interessant darstellen weil sie in
dieser krise
ganz stark ausbrechen und da zum
beispiel ist das für ein guter
stichwortgeber wenn sich das volk
darüber projekt dann hat doch so etwas
wie eine starke entwicklung
stattgefunden ich erinnere mich an ein
volk vor der krise auch in der faz dass
alles was solidarität altruismus zum
leitsatz seines lebens machte abt an das
waren die gutmenschen und plötzlich ist
der einfall teamchef der bücher schreibt
über die solidarität im kleinen ich
denke an ihr buch minimum ist da eine
fehlentwicklung gewesen im
kulturjournalismus zynismus und jetzt
wieder entdeckung der solidarität
ich würde das alles nicht so
verallgemeinern weil jetzt will ich
nichts zu tun aber ich dein wort haben
sie gerade benutzt darüber wurde nicht
so oft sehr wenn man sich mal ich will
auch obama hier nicht zum neuen
heilsbringer machen aber es gibt einen
interessanten aspekt all seiner reden
sie müssen wir darauf achten wie oft er
sich auch im wahlkampf der zionismus
verwendete es ging immer gegen zionismus
dass er das war wie ein argument ja dass
er führte er auch gar nicht mehr und ich
glaube der hat was erfasst was er jetzt
weit über die debatten der 80er jahre
sloterdijk ein anderes hinaus geht in
der tat dieser zynismus war ein
ein effekt ein leider collateral effekt
dieser unglaublich reichen
hedonistischen gesellschaften
er war zum teil auch eine journalismus
der saturiert war das also die
intellektuelle krise der zeitungen fast
größer als die wirtschaftskrise
nee das sagen es jetzt die zeitungen
sind ja gerade die diese debatten führen
ich rede ja von der intellektuellen
szene insgesamt
ich würde das gar nicht das sind
einzelne wissen sie das können sie nicht
mit dem zionismus meine ich etwas ganz
gesellschaftliches das kann man nicht
auf zeitungen beschränken mit dem
zionismus meine ich eben bestimmte dinge
nicht mehr ernst nehmen bestimmte werte
da fängt es an und das müssen gar nicht
so dass sie haben ja begriff genannt wie
altruismus ein anderes es gibt eine gibt
für mich ein beispiel dafür und wenn sie
mir das vorher erzählt hätten hätte ich
nicht geglaubt
der amerikanische senat hat den e mail
verkehr wie ich sagte von lehman
veröffentlicht und dann finden sie im
sommer eine e mail
eines seiner branche die sagen haben sie
zu unsere zahlen sind schlecht das wird
schiefgehen
wir sollten in diesem jahr auf die boni
verzichten schlagen sie vor dem chef per
e-mail und darauf kommt die antwort
zurück ich frage mich nur was haben sie
euch ins trinkwasser getan was ihr da
fordert ist einfach nur peinlich
da sehen sie wie werte plötzlich so 180
grad kippen können ja das ist ja gar
nicht peinlich was die forderten sondern
das ist richtig eigentlich eine tolle
vorschlag gewesen
sie das sind sie zynischen systeme in
denen das alles gekippt ist und darüber
müssen wir reden dann glaube ich müssen
wir bei diesen schlag schlag das ein
schlag tot begriff globalisierung diese
globalisierung war als das darf man ja
nicht vergessen
die galten die wahl nicht abstrakt
sondern sie es immer die ganzen debatten
waren immer wenn wir das und das machen
wird es den menschen besser gehen
das war immer verbunden mit einem
versprechen dieses versprechen ist jetzt
erstmal nicht erfüllt auch da muss man
mal sich anschauen welche des zionismus
eigentlich in dem für alles herhalten
begriff globalisierung steckt
globalisierung ist das etwas was ihre
zeitung
eigentlich bedroht weil plötzlich von
aller welt hier informationen kommen und
das monopol der wissensvermittlung in
einem land dann in frage gestellt
solcher kein monopol geben das ist es
gar nicht
ich bin da gar nicht ich verstehe einer
zeitung als ein ort des denkens das sind
und solange man sich zutraut sozusagen
dinge zu analysieren zu denken und den
ehrgeiz hat es vielleicht dann besser zu
tun als manche andere daran da wird es
immer ein paar darf geben journalismus
ist am ende
wenn er zugibt wissen die krise für
journalismus ist wenn sie permanent
klick strecken im internet machen
möglichst noch mit irgendwelchen sex
eine illusion dass die menschen da auch
noch rauf gehen das ist krise der sonne
wenn das seriöse zeitung
ich schließe das journalismus sind
gewinnspiele in zeitungen die im
internet klassische journalismus wenn
sie voneinander abschreiben
aber das geht viel zeit es ist ja keine
krise des denkens da und die das heißt
und journalismus
es ist eine möglichkeit ich denke mir
jetzt die welt
analysieren sie und bietet diese analyse
an und vielleicht überzeugt die sich
vielleicht bringt die sogar die welt ein
stück weiter dass das in meiderich sein
der ganz gedankliches projekt und
verkäufliches produkt ja was ist ihr
gedankliches projekt das gedankliche
projekt sagen wir so es ist was wir hier
haben ist ein paar der tageszeitung der
versuch mit den mitteln eines einzigen
organs nämlich ihres gehirns aber auch
noch der augen und der uhr natürlich die
welt zu erfassen und zwar in einem
rhythmus gehen uns die natur vorgegeben
hat wir schlafen wir stehen auf unser
gesamtes leben
es organisiert zwischen gestern heute
und morgen
und da gibt es das internet das ist wie
atmen oder wie die uhr wie sekunden und
dann gibt es aber den großen rhythmus
und hier heißt es für diesen rhythmus in
heimischen zeitungen auch umdenken ich
glaube bestimmte tätigkeiten da die wir
brauchen sie gar nicht mehr diesen
rhythmus bieten wir wie die wieder
schlaf träume gibt bieten wir für den
tag den wir begleiten die analyse den
gefahr wirtschaftsteil die unterhaltung
kommt wirtschaftsteil der zeit musste
ich viele jahre genau was sie wollen
sind wollten noch mehr mag noch weniger
regen noch weniger rücksicht auf die
verlierer
warum erfolgt so weiß ich nicht so recht
was er will
also 11 verkürzen das hier das ist ja
auch also ich widerspreche dem dass das
was das das ist ihre vorstellung von
wirtschaft vielleicht das voerder ist
wäre ja noch schöner wenn sie wüssten
was das vertrauen werde das vertrauen
lebt ist wäre ja noch schöner wenn sie
wüssten was ein großes beispiel
gegenstände ein großer künstler will
wir erfinden ja auch die welt jeden tag
neu an was ihr wir haben zwei vorgaben
würde ich sagen wir haben hier gelernt
ich kann nichts gewesen ganz banal
das eine ist total rationalität also auf
bedienen
die nennt der aufklärung das heißt auch
kontroverse debatten zuzulassen und
zweitens und das ist ein zentraler punkt
jetzt aus der situation in der die
schweiz deutschland österreich wir alle
uns befinden
ich bin überzeugt wir befinden uns in
einer transformation unserer
gesellschaft die sehr sehr gewaltig ist
das hat mit diesen demografischen
veränderung zu tun
es ist so als würde sich die rezeptur
jahrhundertelang ist die gleiche reize
verändert sich die rezeptur mehr alte
weniger junge
richtige einbrüche in den
bildungskarrieren usw
und in so einem moment ist eine zeitung
das will das fördert nicht nur dieses
problem benennen sondern gleichzeitig
fast eine energie entfalten wenn man
eine gesellschaft sich diesen problemen
annimmt
dieses aufklärerische ist ja die
resultate der zeitung sie wurden im
zeichen der aufklärung gegründet und
deshalb auch ihre pressefreiheit und
trotzdem sind wir auch im show zeitalter
sie selbst kommen ja nicht umhin zum
beispiel vor abdruck ihres buchs in der
bild zeitung zu haben die eine gedruckte
show ist muss man da als herausgeber
einer ernsthaften zeitung immer wieder
aufpassen nicht auch zum schon menschen
zu werden nein oder erst recht über die
medien verbindungen in die show
medienwelt näher sind da sind wir noch
mehr druck halten man kann es nicht man
muss in der heutigen gesellschaft das
ist gewiss sagen eine wir müssen uns
gibt konkurrenten machen es auch wir
müssen öffentlich figuren zum teil
jedenfalls sein
in diesem fall geht es darum ich möchte
wenn ich ein buch schreibe eine
größtmögliche öffentlichkeit erreichen
das ist ja klar ich kann sie nicht in
der eigenen zeitung das ging ja etwas
weit dann müssen sie sich natürlich
gerade in diesem bereich der
demographischen frage müssen sich
natürlich transmissionsriemen für so
eine öffentlichkeit suchen ich wäre es
wäre ja die gestaltung ist sie nun
wahrlich kein aufklärerisches organe ps
geht dann wenn sie einen vordruck wie
man das hat mir fest an seinen büchern
der mann demonstriert dann können sie
echt menschen erreichen ich wäre dann
nicht so von oben herab
ob die bild zeitung ein aufklärendes
organ ist das will ich gar nicht
diskutieren aber das ist ja mein buch
und dass das auf leere start von bin ich
überzeugt und daran soll sich auch
nichts geändert
ich würde nicht die leser solcher
zeitungen wie sie das tun von vornherein
als nicht fähig solche aufklärerischen
impulse zu sehen obwohl ich natürlich
die kritik insgesamt an einem
medienzirkus er dass ich nehme einen
ganz anderen bereich den weinmarkt über
die letzten 20 30
wir sind weltweit die reine besser
geworden und mit ihnen gestiegen sind
auch die kenntnisse der weintrinker
haben wir es nicht in der eigenen
branche mit der spirale nach unten statt
noch zu tun dass ein teil des publikums
durch boulevardblätter durch die
privatisierung auch ernster blätter
verdummt wird und dadurch das publikum
auch an qualität einbüßen könnte also
entgegen das ist so offensichtlich was
sie sagen dass man da gar nicht
eigentlich darauf antworten kann weil
das ist ja das diskutieren wir ja im
vertrauen permanent natürlich ist da
eine verdummung spirale sowohl durch den
boulevard wie vor allen dingen muss man
immer wieder sagen durch das fernsehen
bei uns sehr stark durch das
privatfernsehen aber leider auch zum
teil des öffentlich rechtlichen das kann
man ja gar nicht bis dahin warten
das kann man ja gar nicht bestreiten
aber da kann es ja nicht stehen bleiben
sie müssen jetzt sehen da sie diese
diese prozesse haben müssen sie jetzt
sehen wie sie etwas dagegen tun sie
können ihren milieus bleiben
sie ist es sehr sehr schwer den großen
qualitätszeitung ob die faz ist die neue
zürcher oder die süddeutsche sehr sehr
schwer dienen sozusagen ein fahrrad der
journalismus an die unterhaltung vor
aber wie kommt das dass ein solcher
branche wenn es schlecht geht wenn es
krisen gibt wenn die wirtschaft lahmt
die tendenz in den meisten medien hören
ist das niveau zu senken
andere browser wollen je schlechter die
lage ist desto bessere pro jahr das
stimmt das bedauere ich sehr der weg
aber ich muss ja immer sagen sie reden
hier
das ist schlimm und dann können wir nur
über diese sendung appellieren an die
verleger ist nichts zu machen
aber ich sage noch einmal die großen
qualitätszeitungen also wir zumindestens
gehen diesen weg nicht wir sagen es auch
immer wieder wir dürfen die qualität
nicht senken sollte allerdings eines
tages situation eintreten wo niemand
mehr diese qualität wird und dafür nicht
mehr bezahlen und dann sieht das
natürlich anders aus die sehe ich nicht
die qualität heißt wie sie mit recht
sagen ein riesiges korrespondentennetz
eine hoch ausgebildete redaktion nicht
für auflage irgendwelche fotos auf die
erste seite machen die sozusagen
bestimmte reflexe bedient auch nicht
bestimmte themen groß spielen die alle
anderen haben usw aber als erster
da sehe ich ab und zu auf dieser ersten
seite der frankfurter allgemeinen titel
die früher gar nicht vorgekommen wäre
ein mord in ostdeutschland und schon mit
dem vornamen des mordopfers wird das
auch bei ihnen thematisiert heißt da
nicht auch ein bisschen eine gefährdung
durch das ja ich verstehe dass sie ein
ganz ganz redeten ja auch im weinkontor
vom wir reden also was reinheit angeht
und so weiter sie können doch den
schauen sie sich doch mal die große
kunst und kultur und und die diese
welten an
sie können doch nicht das wäre ja nun
wirklich fatal wenn wir hier eine eine
quarantäne aufmachen würden für unsere
tollen intellektuellen nicht sozusagen
für unterhaltung oder auch versuchen
eine suggestion zu erzeugen bei menschen
die wir sonst nicht erreichen was wir
hier machen
mit diesen bildern die er sehr sehr gut
ankommen ist ja was symbolisches also
dass bedarf schon einer hohen
abstraktionsgrad um da sozusagen auch
den das zu genießen
dass das jetzt ein beispiel dafür sein
soll dass sich das privatisiert das hat
sich dann nicht das bild also weil sie
das gerade so sagt ich erwähnte dass
sozusagen mordfälle plötzlich auch auf
der ersten seite ihrer zeitung erscheint
ist es ein bekannter der fall sein
dürfte von der trivialität verschont
aber werben nur einem teil des publikums
nein das ist nicht so dass sagen sie das
ist ich finde dass gerade zum beispiel
gucken sie mal da werden bilder des
alten ägypten gezeigt wo menschen aus
gepeitscht wird vom steuereintreiber und
sollte das ist natürlich ein brot das
ganze das ist auch ein versuch was viel
interessantes und da gebe ich ihm ja
wieder recht ist wir haben dieses bild
ja auf die eins gemacht und es hat auch
sehr gut funktioniert weil wir vorher
ganz puristisch waren und vorher gesagt
nur text und kein bild und ich sage auch
darum ich will nur nicht in die falsche
debatte gezwungen die boulevardisierung
der medien schauen sie sich an was ein
mann wenige meyer da im internet
permanent mädchen schon und das ist der
medien sei es ja auch der findet ja die
ungeheuerlichsten fälle auch manchmal
abend leider bei uns manches was nicht
gut ist und das ist ja sehr dankenswert
dass man das sieht das würde ich ja nie
bestreiten dass ich alles nicht es
scheint dass das
aber für mich ist diese debatte immer
nur hat immer nur eine antwort ja umso
wichtiger dass wir qualitätsjournalismus
hat das deutsche volk thomas ist das hat
sie stellen fragen das deutsche theater
ist erstmal das deutschsprachige vater
es ist im reich ranicki zu zitieren ein
ort wo man ich zitiere ihn jetzt wo man
den hass kennen lernt viel größer als in
allen anderen teilen weil das sind im
ganzen kultur erleben so aber ich würde
schon sagen dass deutsche förderung in
qualitätszeitung ist etwas worum uns
viele andere beneidet haben und auch
noch immer bleiben dass sie auch für
einen seite ist dass ein weltkulturerbe
würde ich sagen
und auf der anderen rechtsschutz und auf
der anderen seite der hort von absoluten
die letzten absolut ist in unserer zeit
sind doch die buch kritiker die vielen
kritiker die theaterkritiker die sagen
lebe oder sterbe und jetzt haben sie
genau unsere ganze debatte hier in einem
symbol das habe ich auch immer ja beim
wandel sollen dieses die eu muss man
eigentlich müssen wir erkennen dass er
das behaupten aber jetzt kommt na das
ist ja nicht klar ja moment ich rede ja
von mir jetzt kommt aber der punkt
dieses zu tun hat ja selber wieder jetzt
werden wieder sagen oh gott aber hat ja
selber wieder ein unterhaltungs effekt
und das muss auch seine kultur muss auch
was unterhalten das haben das heißt dass
ego dass sich verrennt ob es der reich
ranicki ist er sagt dieses buch ist ein
meisterwerk oder wir haben einen
schlechten bücherherbst oder ein anderer
wie joachim kaiser in der süddeutschen
der stadelmaier bei uns wir wollen ja
den temperamentvollen kritiker der sein
ego und sich damit nach vorne schickt
aber sich damit natürlich auch
angreifbar macht sie können es eben
nicht so trennen wir haben zum glück
nicht mehr die völlig unverständlichen
intellektuellen porträtisten der 60er
jahre die aus 68 zum teil kam die
verstand kein mensch es gehört dazu auch
ein bisschen löhne
das ist nun einmal so und diese egos
sind dann ja auch entsprechend schauen
sie sich die großen kritiker unserer
gesellschaften an die sind dann ja auch
entsprechend gut wenn man sie in der
öffentlichkeit präsentiert bei ganz
anderen sachen absätze reicher nichts
geht über das fernsehen ist oder joachim
kaiser über die musik trotzdem hat das
volk seine wunderbaren seiten wenn es
debatten
wie sie skizziert haben und auf der
anderen seite eine so furchtbare
selbstverliebtheit man muss sich ihn
durch viele viele girlanden durchkämpfen
bis irgendwo mal der artikel endlich zum
punkt kommt sie reden jetzt wie ein
blatt kritiker weil der faz und auch
sicherlich bei anderen zeitung ich bin
da ganz lernfähig also ich würde jetzt
ganz sagen dass das nicht stimmt auch
hier gibt es große meister von denen man
lernen kann und ich glaube da hilft uns
auch wiederum das internet dass wir
nämlich etwas sehe er auch einfach
erkennen
jannis gesagt immer selbst bei goethe
muss man dazu schreiben deutscher
schriftsteller aber dass wir einfach
erkennen es muss viel negativer
erzählerischer werden würde ich jetzt
nicht was ich eben finde sie sagen so
sehr absolut es gibt solche leute es
gibt natürlich nicht bei uns aber es
gibt solche vor journalisten gleich gab
es auch mal den einen oder anderen bei
uns und da kann ich nur sagen sofort
weil jede leser kritik auf sowas wird
sehr ernst genommen
der leser hat immer recht bei solchen
fragen und theaterkritiker natürlich
auch er ist ein machtmensch der kritiker
hat recht was obwohl er ja auch seine
fehler eingesteht gibt es viele fälle
hat recht in dem augenblick wo er
schreibt unsere urteil abgibt aber dann
ist er genauso angreifbar wie alle
anderen und ich sage ihnen eins niemand
ist empfindlicher
niemand ist sensibler als die kritiker
in diesem lande austeilen aber nicht
einstecken ja sie müssen es ja sie
müssen ja einstecken und die müssen auch
einen weg finden damit umzugehen er nur
noch mal reich ranicki das ist heute
ganz vergessen
der war in den 70er 80er jahren ja sowas
von umstritten da gab es ja
schriftsteller berühmte fälle die ihn
sogar ein maschinengewehr umbringen
wollten oder erschießen wollte einer
berühmten situation also den dc stecken
auch schon ein die kritik an das kann
man nicht sagen
sie sind eine eigenes temperament und
wir müssen alles dafür tun dass solche
gewächse auch nachwachsen dazu bedarf es
übrigens zeitungen die sie schützen
dazu bedarf es nicht verleger die dann
wenn irgend jemand anruft gilt den
ganzen journalismus jetzt sagen was hast
du da wieder geschrieben sondern das ist
genau der raum der freien zeitungen mit
den nicht mehr
werden wir solche menschen nicht mehr
haben und die brauchen wir auch dann zum
beispiel ums fernsehen zu kritisieren
oder uns kritisieren zu lassen
diese freien menschen brauchen freie
arbeitsräume und die werden garantiert
von zeitungen die entsprechend ticken
sie wir erwähnten wiederholt marcel
reich ranicki wo sich in seiner
persönlichkeit verbindet die unendliche
liebe zur literatur und ein machtwillen
der spürbar war
und dasselbe spürt man ja eigentlich bei
ihnen die taz die berliner tageszeitung
beschrieb sie als der mächtigste für ton
ist der republik also es mit ihnen zu
verraten dass wir schon unangenehm oder
das kann nicht sein denn es haben sich
so viele schon mit mir verdorben und
denen sagt also das ist das sind alles
symbole das sind alles fiktion heute
stimmt das so morgen stimmt das so das
ist nicht ich was ich habe und was ich
will ist folgendes und das haben wir
glaube ich durch die faz das waren wir
ja alle auch sehr nach vorne gebracht
debatten führen nicht um ihrer selbst
willen aber debatten die system erkennen
und die debatte daran anschließen heißt
auch irgendwie mal zum ergebnis kommen
und ich glaube dass das etwas ist was
dann auch nicht so dieser ewige roman
sondern dass man tatsächlich dann
bestimmte dinge auch irgendwann sagt so
sind sie jetzt für mich entschieden und
da hatte ich auch viele debatten aber
solche zuschreibung die gibt es immer
wieder und bei jedem die die sind sowas
von relativ da muss man sich glaube ich
nicht weiter mit 34 werden sie
mitherausgeber der faz sie sind jetzt 48
glüht die leidenschaft noch
also ich hätte nie gedacht dass briefe
dass das dass das hätte ich gedacht dass
ich jetzt nicht hier das einmal ein
internet kommt solche kommunikationsform
kommt ich muss sagen ich ziehe ich sie
glüht total aber es ist noch was anderes
ich habe das gefühl dass wir echt auch
was unsere historische zeiten erleben
und das ist ja noch schöner wäre wenn
wir nicht jetzt das nutzen könnten für
das was wir wollen
denn das was wir wollen ist nichts
schlimmes so nicht schlecht dass sondern
was sehr gut dass wir wollen
interessante medien gestellt
wir wollen eine interessante zeitung
machen und darum bin ich eigentlich sehr
sehr stimuliert mich beschäftigt sehr
dass diese probleme jetzt in vielen
zeitungen auch in der schweiz etwas mit
den sondern die die zukunft nicht nur
von journalisten sondern auch der
nächsten generation von journalisten
das ist etwas sehr sehr ernstes denn wir
brauchen diese jungen leute die auch
sozialisiert werden in zeitungen oder in
medien insgesamt
und wenn das noch eine weile so
weitergeht wird das unangenehm werden
und dann ist übrigens kein medium von
der debatte wird keinesfalls sprechen
wir von den journalisten gibt es da
nicht eine zweiklassengesellschaft bei
qualitätsblätter die auf der einen seite
die wohl bestanden redakteure und auf
der anderen seite die freien mitarbeiter
die für hungerlöhne und ein minimales
zeilen honorar im grunde genommen
qualitätsarbeit verrichten
also ich kann auch hier sie stelle mir
immer fragen für andere ich kann das
will uns beantworten es ist kein
hungerlohn und war es nie gewesen im
gegenteil also bei weitem nicht es ist
gleichzeitig eine ganz große karriere
sprungbrett gewesen
wir können ohne weiteres auch freie
mitarbeiter verzichten wir können das
anders organisieren
ich kenne die debatte die sie meinen
also ich bin das hier nummer trennen
damit das nicht was sozial gemein stand
ich weiß dass tatsächlich so etwas
passiert und auch so passt systematisch
passiert die das geht nicht nur um freie
mitarbeiter es geht da auch eine praktik
praktikanten usw
das ist ein problem mit dem sich die
verleger auseinandersetzen müssen wir
konnten uns das so gar nicht leisten
weil wir brauchen ja auch qualität bei
den freien mitarbeitern und sie werden
selten es gibt sicherlich mein fall war
einer sagte das war zu wenig oder dass
ich bin ausgebeutet worden
aber ich glaube das ist zumindest schon
sehr sehr sehr selten für doch sagte
unlängst deutlich werde ich von meinen
freien mitarbeitern subventionieren ja
was soll ich dazu sagen es bei uns nicht
so wir haben ja ich habe mir ganz wieder
redakteure und korrespondenten würden
sie einem ja ich kann es
ich sage wissen sie unser ich war auch
mal freie mitarbeiter das sind ja talent
pools und so wir dürfen ja nicht das was
jetzt in der wirtschaftskrise passiert
jetzt sozusagen also ich rede jetzt nur
von der versicherung kann unsere zeit da
dürfen wir jetzt nicht dass systematisch
ab schlussfolgerungen daraus ziehen
ich würde immer sagen subventionierten
einem fast metaphysischen sind werden
wir von den jungen redakteuren die in
der zeitung sind und die wir unter allen
umständen halten müssen und auch ihre
ihre freude an der zeitung erhalten
müssen das ist etwas was ein wechsel auf
die zukunft ist das was sie jetzt
zitieren das kann sicherlich so seien
wahrscheinlich ist dass eine zeitung die
fast nur aus frauen mitarbeitern besteht
sie müssen mal sehen wer da so habe ich
es gelernt auf der ersten seite an der
zeitung wie oft steht da dpa wie oft
steht da ap wie oft steht er aber
nachrichtenagentur genau die
nachrichtenagentur wie oft steht da aber
ein name eines menschen der für die
zeitung heißt bei uns fast systematisch
nun der fall
das ist der unterschied ja ich verstehe
dass es gibt zeit um die leben viel von
außen
wir tun es ihm bewusst nicht noch einmal
das ist meinen augen
qualitätsjournalismus 10.000 vielleicht
sogar schon 15.000 journalisten in der
bundesrepublik sind arbeitslos in diesem
lande der schweiz wurden in den letzten
monaten 500 journalisten etwa entlassen
ist das überhaupt noch ein zukunftsberuf
und stark dass nicht ungemein
einstellung der verleger gegenüber
leuten die koste es was es wolle
beziehungsweise bringe es nichts ein was
es wolle arbeiten möchten
also ich erstens stelle ich fest sie
haben ein negatives menschenbild es kann
so sein ich würde es ja wissen gefragt
ich eher ich es kann so sein natürlich
dass es bei also dass die zeitarbeit und
so weiter wenn sie klug sind machen sie
es nicht so aber dann wollen sie keinen
massiven sie qualität wollen geht es so
nicht sie können das ist dass sie können
qualität für hungerlöhne bekommen das
geht nicht aber zur frage also ist es
nur ein appell ich was soll ich sagen
ich würde mich dem auch immer wieder
setzen natürlich gibt es jetzt eine
krise aber es geht ja sozusagen um einen
konsens den man immer so etwas hat bei
der
anderen frage ist es noch ein
zukunftsberuf ist natürlich ein
zukunftsberuf zone ohne frage
ich sehe ein großes problem allerdings
darin dass wenn die krise sich
verschiebt wir zu stark ich will das gar
nicht in abrede stellen ist ganz wichtig
öffentlich rechtliche system aber wir
können nicht es so haben dass jeder der
journalist werden will denn das sind die
einzigen die funktionieren im augenblick
richtig gut also jetzt aufgrund der
gebühren in die öffentlich-rechtlichen
systeme geht und wir dann in
journalismus haben der aus dem
öffentlich-rechtlichen raum heraus kommt
das wäre wirklich nicht gut
die zeitungen wir alle wären riesigen
teil und vor der krise talentschmieden
und das muss auch so weitergehen die
frankfurter allgemeine sonntagszeitung
die auf der grünen wiese entstanden ist
hat die hatte diese leute dann permanent
abgeworben seit jahren immer wieder
bleiben zum glück
das sind talent spielen das sind und das
wird ja in jeder generation wieder so
weiter gehen und damit kann man nur
hoffen dass diese krise jetzt nichts so
ist wie massiv wird dass das dazu einem
ausfall einer ganzen generation wird das
diktum lautet qualität kommt von qual
autorität kommt von autor diese qualität
dieser autorität die eher wird man ja
nicht von heute auf morgen zufall dass
ihre zeitung eine der älteren ist und ja
auch gründer der tradition vor dem
zweiten weltkrieg der frankfurter
zeitung dass fast alle qualitätsblätter
auf der welt die ältesten sind im lande
eine zeit die von gerd bucerius
gegründet wurde brauchte ein
vierteljahrhundert um endlich mal in die
schwarzen zahlen zu kommen und verleger
hatte diesen langen atem der qualität
wegen um der qualität würden hierdurch
zu halten haben wir heute einen
kapitalismus der solche
langen atem der ist nämlich der
investition in die qualität gar nicht
mehr ermöglicht gar nicht mehr erlaubt
das halte ich für denkbar
das heißt also wenn es jetzt neu
anfangen würde alles dann wäre meine
prognose ganz schlecht also wenn jetzt
das so wäre dass wertvoller seiten und
jetzt würde man sagen wer glaubt daran
ein produkt einer eine idee 20 jahre zu
finanzieren 30 jahre
dann wäre meine prognose ganz schlecht
aber die gibt es ja diese was passiert
dass es gab auch auf dem zeitungsmarkt
eine hybris das sehen sie an den
verschuldungsquoten der new york times
in vielem anderen das muss man ganz klar
sehen
es gab ein paar die alle haben fehler
gemacht aber es gab wirklich ein paar
sie haben jetzt ja auch namen genannt
ich würde noch bei anderen die den lang
an den langen atem glaubten und glauben
denken sie in die 70er jahre sein
zeitung ganz anders aus daran so viel
dünner hatten dann wuchsen sie jetzt
haben wir vielleicht eine
gesundschrumpfung prozess ein bisschen
das kann schon sein
diese leute haben mit zeitung immer
etwas anderes verbunden als nur
anzeigenblätter oder fehlt der respekt
vor der eigenen leistung es gab das
schöne wort nachricht das ist etwas
wonach ich mich richten uns gibt
orientierung dann kam das wort news so
heißt ja auch in österreich und magazin
und als dritte und das der stufe sind
wir jetzt beim content und content ist
alles ist nicht geheilt sondern in hoya
kann journalistisch oder nicht
journalistisch seien sehr unabhängig
oder nicht unabhängig ja und da ist
jetzt die pc sehen da ja auch jetzt
keine sozusagen alle bucerius oder
unserer gründe keine gründungs figuren
in dem klassischen sind sie haben einen
news aggregator wie google mit einer
abstrakten sozusagen erster extrakten
mathematischen systemen aber sie haben
eigentlich nicht dieses neue und da muss
man schon sagen diese leute die diese
zeitung gemacht haben und alle die
erfahrung der krise des zweiten
weltkriegs hinter der krise und des
zweiten weltkriegs hinter sich und die
haben wir zeitungen etwas ganz anderes
verbunden und dieses was sie damit
verbunden hatte hatte wenn man es anders
formuliert immer auch mit einem
misstrauen gegenüber der stabilität
unserer systeme zu tun
so entstanden
änderungen und darum wollten sie auch
kritik daran haben sie auch dafür
gesorgt dass der freiheit möglich ist
durch die konstruktion und soweit sie
hätten in der vergangenheit nämlich rede
von den gründern sind wird in der
saurier hinein für den
qualitätsjournalismus erstellen denn
jünger was ist denn jünger und frischer
als das wo gerade weil wir die plattform
brauchen wo ist es denn erreicht dass
gesamtgesellschaftlich besser als zu
einer haltung sie muss sich vermählen
also verbinden mit modernen technologien
aber in einer welt in der der gälischen
völlig recht prophet kommerz ganz
kurzfristiges denken immer immer
sozusagen miralles projekt dann ist
glaube ich die prognose für jemand der
so nicht denkt viel viel besser als das
noch in der vergangenheit war
wie sieht ihr fazit den zehn jahren aus
ja da hätte ich ihn früher für viele
jetzt bin ich natürlich vorsichtig weil
ich nicht weiß wie viel neue geräte es
dann endgeräte es gibt ich glaube dass
die faz insgesamt sich sicherlich viel
stärker noch als sie sich das heute
vorstellen können auf grundlagen
hintergründe oft sozusagen auf die
vertiefung konzentrieren wird
sie wird auf vielen plattformen laufen
ich mir fehlt die phantasie mir
vorzustellen wie die faz in zwanzig
dreißig oder vierzig jahren aussehen
kann weil ich immer findet das so wie
sie heute ist sie schon sehr sehr gut
ist frank schirrmacher vielen dank für
dieses gespräch
[Musik]
auch wenn es sich anbieten würde
gedruckt gibt dieses gespräch nicht
dafür aber auf dvd bestellen können sie
wie immer hier schweizer fernsehen
redaktions sternstunden 80 52 zürich
ihre e mail erreicht uns unser stern
kobinet sf.tv